hey boats hey boats why I need a poop
this go away I'm too tired
I am I go poop on your pillow whatever I
boats why I need food olessa gonna have
to cook something yourself boats what
why don't you just give me what's over
there sorry too much effort
mmm you become fat and lazy put this on
it's time to shape up who's ready buff
I am was that not the most badass in
true you've ever seen you know you're
serious about exercising when you got a
scrunchie in your hair so this is me now
huh I'm a skinny alcoholic well let's
have right at least does jump Crouch as
fast as possible all the lard police
make me get through this one like
studious I got there was your clothes
Oh God my [ __ ] is that we do what I'm
puttin my town [ __ ] ha ha yes hit the
deck ah ha oh so much bread
no no gesture then run it learn it ha ha
ha
chef I can't do this anymore oh yeah
uh help me sell my place I really need
to play this game like everyday to get
in shape I check what do you want from
me oh oh yes I did it all right huh huh
no [ __ ] how do I even oh my buddy's too
big damn it oh please tell me i won
damnit waterfalls very motivating for me
I got it I sense your sarcastic chasm
dirt of course
yeah it was timing out that's right I
don't even need to wear a helmet that's
our cool I am
but I don't have any skates
yes I feel it
so like I'm doing a great job that's
right yes I was born to do this all the
video game time for pillion of some
ninja all right [ __ ] it's all phony
sorry how does she do it
how fix it
hi I gotta get a heart attack 5x know
what if this so much produce all the
burgers Oh Brutus record your special
mode to save it God Squad me to the moon
I'll do this just because I want an ass
like Nicki Minaj make a squat to move oh
yeah don't move Oh squirt me God Squad
yes I am the power ah ah you remember
your moon
dirty Florida babies regulate Bobby baby
ah
alright so awesome ah fly under wing
soon make a dragon Fred booty paw thank
you squatting total moon baby totem move
one squirrel at a time we will purge
this planet from evil oh never been so
badass in my laughs thank you sir we did
it oh I'm so happy it was awesome
again you not seen these legs there what
you popped what is this
we're on the top of the mountain oh I
got this ha ha ha catch huh Alina's ah
so much bonus I can't I can't
I'm sorry I just came but when we're
training tomorrow oh so much much
outside see there so that was shape up
surprisingly enough I actually had fun
working out it's a really cool game I
definitely think he bros to check it out
the game is an xbox one exclusive I'll
leave a link to the trailer and the game
to check out in the description or in
the outro thank you for leaving a like
on this episode bros and as always stay
awesome bros